key comment that I have made is about
Harriet Harman and her position in this
report when before she became chairman
she had publicly tweeted her criticisms
and her disbelief in Boris Johnson and
you must remember that the law Lords and
the law Lords were a committee of
parliament exactly the same way as
privileges committee had the Hoffman
principle we're not Hoffman ruled on
Pinochet and his wife was a member of
amnesty he had to have that judgment set
aside because of the appearance of
partiality and it seems to me that
exactly the same applies to Harriet
Harman the appearance of partiality
because of what she tweeted meant that
she was not the right person to be the
chairman and Chris Bryant had stood
aside for exactly that reason and that
once you have a chairman who shouldn't
be the chairman then you undermine the
whole report but so Jacob the criticisms
leveled at the committee by Boris
Johnson and some of his supporters have
been far beyond just Harriet Harmony you
suggesting had Harriet Harman recused
herself then you would have found
legitimacy in this report because I
don't think you would have my main
criticism has been about Harriet Harmon
being the chairman of this committee but
this is obviously a political event that
the houses of Parliament that the high
court of parliament is political it is
fundamentally political and everybody
knows that and one of the aspects of
democracy the report complains about tax
on Democracy this is nonsense the
fundamental of democracy is freedom of
speech and the idea that you can't
criticize Parliament or Committee of
parliament is absurd if the transport
committee comes out with a report saying
I don't know that we should turn the
Thames into a Motorway we're allowed to
criticize it we're allowed to say it's a
Bonkers report that is freedom of speech
has
have you read the report and has it
changed your view on Mr Johnson I wrote
the report carefully and there are a
couple of things it might be worth
highlighting one is that they seem to
think they can get into Boris Johnson's
mind and find him guilty of misleading
um because they think they know what he
was thinking so when he goes upstairs
they think that he must have noticed
well they have no evidence for that
that's just a supposition I'd also say
that I was leader of the house at the
time and I was briefed for business
questions to answer
wire party is going on and the briefing
I was given the line to take was exactly
the same as the prime ministers and that
is that the rules were followed at all
times with emphasis on all times so I
think they have come to conclusions that
are not fully supported by the evidence
and there's one very interesting thing
if you look at the back look at appendix
they make a response
to the comments Mr Johnson makes and
what they think he should have said but
they leave out they don't respond to the
key point he makes about Harriet
harman's position sorry it's appendix
one appendix one and appendix 3 is
Johnson's statement and they say they go
through all Johnson's questions in his
letter of the 9th of June but they
ignore this key point which they fail to
answer and that seems to me to be just
as serious as some of the things they
accused Boris Johnson of they answer
selectively they don't answer that
fundamental point a chairman who
expressed her view prior to the case so
Jacob it seems that kind of the the the
the the the kind of guardrails if you
like all the lines are set in this and
that Boris Johnson supporters are not
going to be
move to find another position on the
findings of this report but just to be
clear before we move on when it comes to
Harriet Harman you believe that if she
had recused herself the committee would
have had more legitimacy definitely if
you had found a labor MP who had made no
comment about Boris Johnson that would
have established a committee with
considerably more Authority and look
what Chris Bryant did Chris Bryant
recused himself because he had done what
Harriet Harman had I imagine many of
your colleagues in the comments will be
shouting at the television at this point
saying it was a 14th month investigation
it was asked for by the House of Commons
it was a cross Party Committee they have
studied
so much evidence and they have come to
this conclusion and that by criticizing
it you and Boris Johnson and his
supporters are undermining the
undermining the legitimacy of democratic
institutions many people might first of
all who drafts the report that the
committee agrees
the chairman they vote on the Chairman's
draft the influence of the chairman is
fundamental to select committees and the
idea that you can't criticize select
committee reports or their operations is
absurd and the House of Commons used to
try and be very precious about its
privilege and called John Junior to the
bar of the house and it makes itself
look foolish when it is precious put it
another way to you sir Jacob because you
like process
was it right for Boris Johnson to
basically breach confidentiality having
been given a copy of the report by on
Friday resigning and effectively
revealing some of not the detail of the
report do you think he should have done
that you you qualify yourself quite
rightly you say effectively you didn't
reveal the details of the report he
obeyed the confidentiality but he
decided to say that he breached it well
they say that by deciding to resign he
breached it but they can't point to any
individual item where he's breached it
but you've been listening to the radio
into the media and you will no doubt
have heard
journalists say sources close to the
committee have told them that is a
breach of privilege if any member of the
committee or Clerk of the committee has
briefed a journalist anonymously that is
a breach of privilege and I think they
should take the motor out of their own
eye the beam out of their own eye before
trying to take the most out of Boris
Johnson's okay so Jacob it seems to me
that the report is out and really the
positions were set before the reporters
out and it's not really changing the
narrative around Boris Johnson I think
there's one thing that's changed and
that this is this 90-day suspension
which is extraordinary I think it shows
that the report is
um
deliberately trying to do damage to
Boris Johnson it is Way Beyond a
Judicial sanction
um very few people have got sanctions of
this kind but sometimes the most serious
offenses prime minister and the
committee has found that multiple
contempts of parliament he was the Prime
Minister
should be greater because of the
responsibility he bought for most of the
contempts they find he wasn't prime
minister they find most of the contempts
are about how he responded to them which
I think when you're defending yourself
to say well we don't agree with the way
you've defended yourself is a very odd
way of proceeding but no I think their
fundamental judgment is wrong because I
don't think he deliberately misled
Parliament and I think he tried to
correct the record when he could and
there's good evidence for that but I
think the 90-day sanction shows
um more than perhaps the committee would
like to show and what about his past
being revoked it was trivial I mean
that's just uh
um so it's like switching off a child's
Nintendo
um 10 minutes early well that would be
very serious in my house if I dare do
that to be honest but just on
what happens next I've got two questions
for you uh the fast is is there any way
back politically for Boris Johnson after
this is he done is he finished oh this
sort of report has no long-term effect
on people's political careers if you
think of John Wilkes in the 18th no
effect on his career no no well he's
left Parliament so it's had that effect
but once he'd left prime minister he can
come back if he comes back this report
is ineffective because if you are
adopted and voted for by the electric I
mean this overrules a parliamentary is
he too damaged from this can he come
back will he come back it depends on the
Judgment people come to I think many
people will look at 90 days and will
think that that is simply too harsh too
aggressive and shows what the committee
was really trying to do I think this
will generate sympathy for him but he is
still a popular National figure he still
has a connection with voters that most
politicians would give their eye teeth
for next question does it reopen a Tory
Civil War in the Commons Penny Morden
said let people vote how they choose to
vote and leave us alone to do it and I
felt that that was an an indication of
some of the tensions and precious
colleagues are under over the vote well
there is normally a free vote on a House
of Commons business so that's not
atypical
but is this opening up divisions again
in the conservative party over Boris
Johnson versus Richard I mean it is
isn't it didn't somebody once say we're
a nest of singing birds creating dogs I
think it was Boris Johnson when he was
having a massive round with Theresa Mayo
I think it was I remember I was there
well I remember him also saying that but
I think nest of singing birds is the
lion's take
um how do you think the vote will go
because you have the whole of the
opposition uh against him any opposition
would always vote against a previous
prime minister but you also have
um the Boris haters in the conservative
party so so there are borisations
vote against him of course there are how
many do you think will vote against I
have no idea
how damaging will it be for MPS to vote
against him and then have to go back and
face their constituency
I wouldn't even want to faintly imply
that MPS should be influenced by outside
uh factors and how they vote that I
think would be a breach of privilege MP
should always vote as they think right
and proper and never with an eye to how
people will react to it final question
have you spoken to him in the past few
days have you spoken to him today I
haven't spoken to him today but I'm in
touch with Boris and how is he I mean is
he he's curious well he's not better
defeated but he's definitely not
defeated no
is this not The Knockout blow of course
it's not okay I mean you know the worst
thing that happened with this if it fell
on your foot it might give you a bruise
but no more than that I mean so Jacob
you're saying just to be clear that you
don't think that this signals the end of
Boris Johnson the end of his political
career that he has been so compromised
oh no no no no no I'm afraid
this has the effect of making those
people who don't like Boris Johnson
dislike him a bit more and those who do
like him
um think that the Privileges committee
has made do you think he'll be back or
attempt to come back to Parliament
before the next general election not
before the next election
um to all your Tory viewers of whom I
hope there are Legions we must back the
Prime Minister until the next election
we can't change leader again that would
be ridiculous and then after the
election of political combat
um Mr sunak wins with a majority of 250
we won't need way too much about
leadership so you think risky Scenic
will do better than Boris Johnson I'm
not sure I'd go that far well Brothers
Johnson won an 18. recumbent hope
Victoria's successes so Jacob just final
thought from you then of the Fallout of
this
well look they've come to their report I
think many people will think that the
report was badly handled they will come
back to the Hoffman principle and
Harriet harman's role in this and think
that she ought to have recused herself
and that would have made a more valid
report okay thank you so much sir Jacobs
for joining us